first of all can you even take the whole
thing you can't even take this whole
thing it's not possible
[Music]
large big dicks like this are only good
in theory not in usage because I'm not
putting missing this is too big if I saw
this in the wild I would say no thank
you but I feel like whatever size it is
you shouldn't be shamed for it yeah
you're beautiful either way you know
what somebody could do with yeah damage
actual damage actuator and when your
organs are rearranged size doesn't
matter but it's not the most important
thing
how many wieners have you seen in their
life anything I don't think I can count
not that they are wait wait wait so I
guess we are cutting this to the size of
what we think is the average penis okay
I'm gonna do five dollars I think I'm
gonna get this right I'm just gonna call
on my spirit angels wait a second
important question is this the penis
erect yeah that's why you're just that
hard okay flaccid it's like just cut the
tip off I'm just like okay I'm trying to
imagine a bit of a 30-story juices
only hard average oh that's hard though
no no I think you're giving these people
so much credit so now I'm using this
tape to uh i'll tiny bit cuz I cut mine
I think too small
[Music]
that's big I knew it oh my god okay I
don't know what that says about us by
[Music]
I'm actually not surprised
um I know that most penises are like
this and then you're just blessed if you
do have one of these little babies yeah
blessed or cursed whatever you're
working with 3 inches 8 inches it
doesn't matter like you should let me
saw and if you don't I will you choose
the man over not over their penis size
you choose it over what kind of person
they are so like it really doesn't
matter what size your dick is it matters
what kind of a human being you are love
love is what section about there's a
whole lot of sex as you know love it all